so my slides are up I guess that means
I'm starting there's a couple people
still filtering in feel free to come on
in and sit down we're gonna be talking
about micro services with asp net court
today and a couple couple more specific
things that i'll get into in a little
bit so i'm ryan Noack I'm a framework
developer and architect working on asp
net core you could say that I probably
have a particular focus on things like
MVC routing blazer Razer engine language
and tooling all the things that people
use to write applications I'm really
interested in how how people program
things how people use frameworks and how
to make people more productive I'm also
really interested in performance you can
find me on Twitter if you want and
you'll be able to find all my materials
and demos online later my last slide
will have a more comprehensive set of
links to all of the things so today
we're going to be talking about micro
services and I'm going to be talking
about micro services in the context of a
spinet coordinate core and kubernetes
and so what is kubernetes what how would
you use asp net core and kubernetes and
what are some things that we can learn
about performance of donna core and asp
net core in containers that's when it's
on our agenda for today so you might be
asking or you might be reading Twitter
or reading somebody's latest hot take or
latest meme what are micro services are
they the definitive solution to all
applications must you do everything in
micro services today are they just very
small services do you just write less
code do you use different frameworks or
different technologies these are all the
kinds of things you might hear about
micro services if you haven't actually
tried building micro services
applications and the answer I'll give to
to all those questions is like well well
no but sometimes kinda like you might
write less code you might use different
frameworks and tools you might design
things differently if you have multiple
services they might be the solution to
your problem they might cause you
problems so there's some truth in all
the things that we hear about micro
services there's some there's some
aspect of all of those statements that
are true for somebody somewhere at some
time and only you and your company or
your organization or your team
can really decide what's right so
there's a lot of banter on Twitter today
I think maybe the last week in the
developer community at least among some
of the people that I follow in messages
that I see around you know people's hot
takes or rants about you know I wish we
didn't have to do micro services for
everything or we don't have to do micro
services for everything and and that the
truth is that I'm kind of like you like
I'm a framework developer I'm a tools
developer I help people program I work
on the framework I fix bugs that cause
bugs I'm not an application development
consultant or a really like in the
trenches like app application deployment
kind of person I don't have that
experience so the things that I do learn
i hear from blog posts i hear from
talking to customers i hear from
interviewing people or getting their
feedback about what things work and work
well for them and don't work well if i
sort of summed up what i do know and
what i do hear from people it's kind of
that my doing micro services deployment
are doing micro services development or
migrations might make sense for you if
you're going to get something out of it
if you're gonna get the ability to
deploy and develop things separately if
you're gonna get the ability to evolve
parts of your code base or to work more
productively as an organization you
might want to consider that if you don't
feel like you could get those benefits
out of breaking up a larger application
into multiple services let's say maybe
you don't have good discipline around
using source control and CI and you end
having deployment pipelines and having
good ways to do code reviews and check
things in and deploy them to production
and your organization this is probably
not the Silver Bullet that you're
looking for
so I'm not a Salesman presumably you're
here because you wanted to hear some
information I'm not gonna try and
explain to you whether or not that's the
right choice hopefully you can figure
that out for yourself you know your
business better than I do as a framework
developer how I kind of tend to think
about micro services is they're not that
different from not micro services I mean
many of you in the audience I'm sure
have written applications before where
you have a front end and a back end and
then maybe another back end right is
that micro services kinda it's all just
back-end to me the difference the
difference between general back-end
development and microservices
development is that there is a set of
problems that kind of just get like
cranked up right because you've got way
more things that are gonna deploy and
version differently and so there's a set
of problems that are gonna get cranked
up that you're gonna have to invest more
in and you're gonna have to learn more
about solutions to those kinds of
problems if you want to be successful
and that's what we're gonna spend our
time sort of folk focusing on whether or
not you're doing micro service II kinds
of stuff though as a back-end developer
you probably still have those problems
and you probably still care about a lot
of this kind of information even if
you're not really reaching for a micro
services kind of kind of deployment so
we are spoiled for choice in the world
of how to display ploy micro services or
where to run your code like where are
you ultimately publishing to write I
tried to be a gala terian and fair with
whose logo that I put on the slide
despite the fact that I work for one of
these cloud providers I won't say which
one but you can probably guess I tried
to be fair and not make anybody's icon
much larger than anybody else's but
you've got a lot of places where you can
deploy and you can run code today you've
really got a lot of options and how you
deploy where you choose to deploy how
you want to get billed is actually
probably going to have a pretty big
effect on how you write code I would
encourage anybody to think about like as
I'm giving you information and I'm gonna
be focusing on one area in particular
but what what what are the consequences
of the choices you make about how you
deploy code and do they help you do they
hurt you what are the things that you
need to do to compensate for the
weaknesses in that platform or the
things that that platform simplifies for
you how do they help you because we're
gonna be talking today about kubernetes
you probably hear a lot about kubernetes
these days and there are a couple talks
about kubernetes at this conference I
think what some of us developer
developer and developer tools kinds of
people really like about kubernetes is
most of all the fact that kubernetes is
probably the most complicated
sophisticated and powerful deployment
environment you could have it's like
it's like an operating system for
deployments and so as a result you could
pretty much program kubernetes
do anything you want like if you want to
write a piece of code that runs in your
kubernetes cluster that looks at all the
deployments coming in and rejects them
unless they're annotated in a certain
way like people have built kubernetes
infrastructure and projects to do that
you might not even have to build it
yourself right if you want to audit all
the deployments in your in your topology
or all the things that people are doing
like kubernetes is basically just a big
REST API so like you can write that code
and it's pretty easy to do it's pretty
fun to extend kubernetes there's a lot
of great projects out there today that
will help you with those kinds of things
and they're all pretty neutral about
what type of technology you're using
kubernetes really doesn't care it's
primarily based on docker or OCI
container images and it doesn't care
what technology stack you're using it's
very egalitarian in that way and the
community of developers and developer
Doc's around around kubernetes don't
really speak to like well you've got to
be a node developer to use this you've
got to be a Java developer to use this
all the technology that's out there is
for everybody which is pretty awesome
the other great thing about kubernetes
is you can really run kubernetes kind of
anywhere so so all the major cloud
providers have a kubernetes offering if
you want to if you want to go that route
if you want to pay for a managed
kubernetes system likewise you can run
kubernetes on your own you can deploy
your own kubernetes set up and you could
administrate it on your own hardware or
VMs if that's something you want to do
you really have the choice no matter
where you are and where you're doing if
you wanted to do this lastly I think the
thing that's most exciting about
kubernetes as a platform for those of us
that work on platforms and work on
developer tools is that it's it's kind
of like it's kind of like an operating
system like the lot of the leaders in
the kubernetes community are saying
things today like the current wave of
kubernetes usage is like assembly
language right we expect kubernetes as a
platform to grow and evolve and support
more high-level less complicated
application models in the future and so
it's kind of worth learning about some
of the things that it does today from
the point of view of understanding that
better if this seems complicated to you
it probably will be simplified in a few
years which might help you out might be
something that you're looking for
so I'm gonna do a quick demo to
introduce a couple things and hopefully
this hopefully this is at least a little
bit interesting or sort of gives you the
impression of some of the power that you
have with kubernetes now I'm gonna be
doing a lot of things at the command
line here I hope that's okay
kubernetes is sort of a command line
focused tool or a command line first
tool I'm going to be deploying a very
simple dotnet core application and this
is the code right here and the only
thing that I'm really doing in this code
is I'm writing hello world and I'm
writing what IP I'm listening on and
what hostname I'm listening on and then
the way that I deploy this application
is with this with this Hamel manifest
I want everybody if you want to like
take a moment and react in whatever way
you think is appropriate to the fact
that I'm showing you llamo file like if
you want to Sai remember you're being
recorded but like if you want to react
to the fact that there's the Amal here
go ahead I've been working with this for
a while and I can't I can't really
imagine another tool that's better for
the job which I guess sounds a little
bit weird but I can't imagine this being
Jason or something like that like I
think it I think it might actually be
harder if it weren't you Hamill so let
me go ahead and deploy this now I'm
gonna be running some scripts so that
you don't have to watch me fumble around
and fail to type but you will see that
I'm printing to the console what I'm
doing there and so what's going on here
is I've taken that manifest and I've
deployed it to the cluster with this
command if we go back and we look at
this manifest real quick there's two
objects here this is what that - - -
means it means I've got like two
separate declarations in this file I've
got a deployment object and I've got a
service object and they've all just got
lots of stuff like this is really
verbose and confusing and I'm gonna try
and break down the things that matter
because as an application developer a
lot of this does not matter to you and
will not really matter to you a lot of
this is boilerplate code so every object
in kubernetes has got a metadata section
and then the metadata you're gonna find
a name you're gonna find labels labels
are key value pairs but they're for
humans you may find annotations
annotations or key value pairs but
they're for infrastructure and for
machines not going to say too much more
about that other than their ways of
identifying this object the thing that
really matters here is the spec so a
deployment object
in kubernetes a long-lived like server
kind of thing right so I'm gonna have
three replicas you can ignore all this
stuff and each one of those is going to
have one container and it's gonna point
to this image now I've already pushed
this image to my docker hub so this
image is already sitting out there and
I'm gonna expose port 80 and in addition
to that I'm gonna have a service and the
services of type load balancer a port 80
so what's going on with this service
declaration is a service basically
identifies in kubernetes here's a thing
that you can talk to if you're inside
the cluster or in this case because I
made it of type load balancer if you're
outside the cluster here's a thing that
you can talk to that is going to be
running here
the deployment alone doesn't make it
easy to find and talk to you this
deployment the service is what does that
it's going to create DNS records I have
exposed this publicly so that we can
talk to it and using put type load
balancers kind of like the dumbest way
to do that but it's great for demos so
I'm doing that I'm doing it that way and
then over here we're now ready to
explain what the output of this command
is so a pod you can think of as like an
instance of my deployment so I went
ahead and I created this and I use the
watch command so you can see all the
things that happen
and gradually three instances of my
deployment got created that's what you
see here and we ended up with three
separate instances three separate pods
three separate names that are all
running so I'm gonna exit out of that
and my next step here we're just gonna
run a little shell script I'm getting
the public IP of that service that I
just deployed and then I'm sort of
pinging it repeatedly and you can see
that I'm getting responses from
different endpoints here I'm getting
responses from different IP addresses
and different host names is there are
three copies of this service running so
you see I get response from 3348 and I
think I saw a 38 in there I've got three
copies of this thing running the next
thing that I can do is I can upgrade
this deployment so I've got another copy
of my app and my other app is going to
output some different text if I come to
my start up here this one says by the
way this is a second version and other
than that it's pretty similar the only
thing that's different about this is
I've added a health check to it now
health checks has been around in asp net
core for the last couple releases and
you don't necessarily need
health checks package or health checks
infrastructure to do health checks but
we find that it's kind of helpful for a
variety of reasons what I've changed
about this deployment and the way I'm
going to update this is I've told
kubernetes I want you to check that this
thing is ready before you send any
traffic to it that's what this readiness
probe is and I have tweaked these
numbers to be slow so that it's going to
sort of take a little bit of time to
know that this thing is ready and the
whole reason I'm doing that is just for
demo purposes so you can see what I'm
about to show you and then additionally
what I've customized here I've updated
this to the second image of the app but
the other thing that I've customized
here is I've changed the deploying
deployment strategy to rolling update
and I've basically configured this to do
something kind of special and kind of
kind of complicated to explain but easy
to understand why you'd want to do it so
what this is going to do is when I
update this app it's going to create one
copy of the new app wait for that to be
ready and then delete one copy of the
old app and so on so there's never going
to be fewer than three copies of my app
running and it's going to gradually
arrive at the new app being the only one
running so I'm gonna go ahead and start
that this is deploying the new copy of
the ml file and that's running and then
over here in another terminal I'm gonna
run that same command that we ran to
ping it and display the output and if I
did this right we should see that
gradually this is going to switch so you
can see that we haven't started we
haven't started bringing in the new
copies of the service yet and there it
went so you should start to see now
we're gonna get some mixed responses
here we're gonna start seeing some
responses in just a few seconds from our
new app as they come online and it's
taking its time so it says we have to
up-to-date we have three ready and three
available so there we started to see
some traffic from the second version and
you can see that they're sort of
intermingling we're seeing mixed traffic
from the first version and the second
version because both of them are running
in production at the same time and then
as these new instances come online it's
going to it's going to sort of taper off
all the old ones until we get to the
state where every
is transitioned onto the old on to the
new system so this is pretty
sophisticated and I was able to do that
with just a couple lines in llamo I
remember when I was 16 years old and I
was working at an Internet service
provider in Toledo Ohio and we would
literally like change the DNS record and
then like unplug and replug like
different computers to do this kind of
thing to try to do a migration with no
downtime but we've actually done a
migration to an upgrade to a new app
with no downtime in a totally automated
way with just like llamó that we can
source control so I'm gonna go ahead and
clear this up because we don't need that
anymore and get ready for my next thing
okay so that's kind of an intro of some
of the things that you can do with
kubernetes that are pretty powerful so
you might be asking at this point in the
presentation like I'm demoing this on
Mac I'm doing all this at the command
line I'm a Windows developer can I do
this with Windows so I had actually
planned on showing a mix of Windows and
Mac to try and try and hammer that point
home but something bad happened to me I
want to say first that this was not my
fault it was an accident
so I kind of smashed my computer on
Thursday before I came here which is
kind of unfortunate but if you don't
physically break your computer windows
works pretty well for doing kubernetes
and for doing docker WSL to makes it
work really well and I've been using
that pretty happily on my like Windows
workstation at work as well as my
personal Mac which I'm using for this
presentation if you're not a
command-line sort of person vs code has
got really excellent tools for
kubernetes at least as far as being able
to visualize and see what's going on so
if you're more of a command line if
you're more of a GUI type of person and
you want to say right click give me the
logs of this thing or right-click you
know tell me what's going on with this
thing visual visual studio code has got
really excellent UI for doing kubernetes
so as developers there's lots to like
about this first of all the main thing
like all of these small decisions like
the number of replicas or how we're
deploying how we're rolling
how we're doing health checks they're
not things that you configure in some UI
somewhere there are things that can all
be source controlled so like all the
details of your deployment of your
operations that matter you can source
control in a way that is going to help
you and it's going to work with the way
that you flow data and the way that you
do check-ins and things today and lastly
it's a big REST API so like it has a
command line tool that lets you lets you
query stuff and write your own kind of
queries to find out data or find out
what's going on
you can drop to a lower level and write
your own sort of tooling around around
what's going on in your cluster if you
want to do that but there's a lot that's
not great about it and these are some of
the things that we hope get better over
time
so like using docker like I'm getting I
always get the sense when I talk to
people that's like everybody's using
docker but everybody's not happy that
they're using docker
do people feel that way like docker can
be kind of a pain especially in dotnet
when we have multiple projects there are
dependencies of each other there isn't
really a good recipe for that something
that myself and the rest of the asp net
team want to build some tooling to try
and make better in the future it's
something we're thinking about we sort
of understand that the current state of
things is not very good right
additionally there's a lot of concepts
in kubernetes that are probably more
powerful than you need I've shown you
like really basic like day 1 kind of
stuff so far but there's a lot of things
that you can do here that maybe aren't
what you want to spend your time on as a
developer we're hoping that more stuff
gets built on top of kubernetes it's
higher level in the future that's a
little bit more accessible to developers
so that's just kind of a taste of that
we're gonna switch gears a little bit
and talk a little bit more about writing
code and about writing a spinet core
applications and this is the stuff that
I hope really speaks to you if you're a
back-end developer like how do you
communicate between your micro services
what protocols are you going to use what
technologies are you going to use how do
you figure out what endpoints to talk to
on other services how do you manage
configuration and secrets these are all
the this is like your checklist of all
your things to think about if you're
planning micro services development or
micro services deployment these are all
problems these are all the problems that
get scaled up when you have multiple
apps in your system so if you had one
application in your system before and
you want it to call from
you know one component to another like
that was probably a method call in your
code today you might have an abstraction
that you call through so that you can
unit test and so that you can mock
dependencies but now that it's a
different service running on a different
machine it's a distributed computing
problem how do you think about how do I
know the address of that other server
how do I know how do I think about
resiliency or what do I do if that other
service goes down these are not the kind
of things that you had to think about
when your code was all in the same
process then lastly when you do
troubleshooting
what are your set of tools for
visualizing what's going on in your
topology for tracking the performance of
things and for improving that so I've
got a sample app that we're going to
look at solutions to some of these
problems and we're gonna look at the
current state of the world through the
lens of a sort of sample or a basic
prototype kind of app so what I've done
is I've taken the blazing pizza app from
our blazer workshop and I've broken the
back end up into some micro services so
normally the blazing pizza app how it
works is we've got a front-end blazer
application written in in blazer
webassembly that runs in the browser and
we've got a sort of front end a back end
for the front end app that runs as a
regular asp net core server app that's
like an API server for the front end app
what I've done is I've basically taken
all the business logic functionality out
of that app and I factor that in two
separate concerns or separate domains so
we have a menu service which owns things
like what are the set of Pizza specials
that are available what toppings can you
put on pizzas we've got an order service
which owns payment processing and
tracking order history and we've got a
delivery service which is responsible
for making the pizzas and actually
tracking like where is the delivery
person when with your pizza when are
they gonna get there I've also to sort
of mix things up change some of the
communication patterns here so we're
still using good old HTTP and JSON to
talk from my client side app to my
front-end but we're going to use G RPC
to manage most of the communications
between most of the other services and
hopefully you may have heard some things
about G RPC or you may have seen it
before I'll introduce some of those
concepts and show a little bit of what
that feels like to use when we start
talking about the communications between
those different kinds of services and
then additionally I've got some Redis in
there I'm using Redis in this example to
to sort of simulate using it for like
Message Queuing functionality as well as
pub/sub functionality as well as
database like functionality and I like
Redis from a teaching point of view
because Redis is really flexible
technology and it can be used to do a
variety of different things but in
practice you could substitute Redis for
like a proper message queue or like a
proper pub/sub functionality or like a
proper database functionality in all the
cases that I'm doing here I just wanted
to do it with Redis so I did so with
that I'm gonna flip over to my actual
app and let's run this and see it do
something and I am done with this so
over here I've got my blazing pizza app
and make that slightly bigger and this
is our pizza store from the workshop and
you can see that I've loaded in a list
of Pizza specials here so this this list
of pizzas here and these images and
these descriptions are what comes from
our menu service if I open up one of
these pizzas like I think the buffalo
chicken sounds good this list of
toppings comes from our menu service as
well and I can select these so like
pepperoni sounds good and I think I'll
add lobster and then I can I can add
that sort of to my cart over here then I
go to the order page and I'm gonna very
carefully put in all my personal
information so we can deliver this pizza
this is accurate by the way if you want
to send me letters or mail me pizzas
when I press the place order button this
is actually going to submit to our order
service so we're involving our second
micro service so I'm going to go ahead
and order this pizza that's been ordered
and now the delivery service takes over
so our UI is our our front our back-end
for our front-end is talking to the
delivery service and it's going to get
updates from the delivery service so the
delivery service is tracking this driver
now that the pizzas out for delivery and
it's going to be pushing updates out
that are then gonna be seen inside the
browser so we're getting updates about
the status of that Pizza and where it is
and to sort of visualize this a little
bit differently I'm gonna use this other
app here that I've written which is a
map for the managers of pizza stores so
I'm worried that my delivery drivers are
like driving too fast or something like
that so I've got this app
where I can just spy on them and I'll
select an order and you can see that I'm
getting pushed updates to this UI so I'm
tracking pizza order number two and I'm
getting these like latitude and
longitude coordinates sort of pushed
into this app and that's happening is
this this is being delivered and then
we're gonna get closer and closer and
this pizza will will eventually arrive
so those are some of the communication
patterns that are happening inside of
this app and we're gonna break those
down a little bit and talk talk in a
little bit more detail about how they
work why I made the choices I made and
what the technology looks like under the
hood so let's drop to the S code so I'm
opening up this code right now in vs
code so we can take a look at it the
first thing that I want to point out is
remember I've got a client-side blazer
webassembly app that's blazing Pizza
client that I've got right here and I've
got a server-side sort of REST API kind
of app that's acting as a host for the
client side app why would I choose
something like this or why would I do
something like this well the answer is
there's a couple reasons why I might do
it and this is a pretty common
microservices pattern when you've got a
front-end application that's a
client-side application and it's known
typically as the BFF pattern which i
think of as the like best friends
forever pattern but it actually stands
for back-end for your front end and the
the sort of idea here is that it's worth
isolating your client-side application
if it's a true client-side application
from your proper back-end functionality
for a few reasons first of all you may
not use the same type of auth in your
front end application as you want to use
in the rest of your sort of enterprise
and sort of topology the second reason
is you probably don't want a client-side
application sending requests to like 20
different services to fulfill all the
things that it needs like you sort of
know the typical pattern with front-end
applications where you need to talk to
an api gateway or something like that
that then is gonna fan out and do like
two other calls and combine the results
I don't have examples of this in my in
my sample but you you want to try and
limit the number of requests that your
client-side application needs to make if
you can having a back-end application to
sort of fulfill that contract for you
makes things a lot easier so one of the
things that you notice right away is
I've got a few G RPC clients here
because this front-end application or
this this back-end for my front-end
application is going out and fanning out
into like three different G RPC services
so what's going on under the covers here
is I have got these protobuf files and
this is part of the gr PC programming
model I've got these profiles sitting in
a server in my repo and I'm bringing
them in here as G RPC services client
the reason why this is done is part is
explained by understanding a little bit
more about how G RPC works as a
programming model and if you haven't
seen this before this might look
familiar to some other technologies that
you've used in the past G RPC is
fundamentally a contract first kind of
programming language or contract first
kind of messaging protocol where you
define upfront in a specific format what
the contract is going to be between your
services so in this case my menu service
exposes these two endpoints you can get
the list of Pizza specials you can get
the list of toppings and everything
about the data model is described in
this format that is language independent
that is like source controllable and
then what I do is I already showed you
how I import that into blazing pizza dot
server my menu service also imports the
same proto file but it says that it's
importing it as server because the menu
service is going to act as the server
for that RPC so in my menu service I
would expect to see methods like get
pizza specials and get pizza toppings
cool so how this works we'll take a look
at the server side first is in start-up
code you end up registering a G RPC
service here so I've got menu service in
pull which I don't like
imple but the G RPC generated code
already takes menu service from me so I
don't have a better idea
so I'm mapping in menu service as a G
RPC service here in start-up code and
then the implementation of that looks
like this
it looks an awful like lot like an asp
net core controller the only difference
here for G RPC is some of the data types
are different and the fact that they
give you a base class to generate this
the other thing that's different about
doing this kind of programming with G
RPC as opposed to like a REST API is G
RPC is very prescriptive so you don't
see anything in these ants in these
methods
clinicians about like I want to bind
this parameter from the body I want to
bind this parameter from the crew string
I want to return this status code like G
RPC kind of does away with that level of
detail on that level of customization
and it's a very prescriptive format or a
very prescriptive protocol as far as how
data is communicated between clients and
servers so if you think about why would
you choose something like J RPC versus
why would you choose something like HTTP
and JSON well do you first of all do you
need to talk to every client in the
universe within my micro services
topology I don't need to talk to every
every client in the universe I just need
to talk to my applications right so rest
and Jason will give you probably the
broadest set of compatibility for
building an API where as G RPC is going
to work really well for clients that can
speak to your PC which generally means
clients that can do HTTP to G RPC will
simplify a lot of the details for you if
all you want to do is do some very
pragmatic communication back and forth
now what it looks like over here to
consume this service I can go to my
toppings controller which is where I get
the list of toppings so you can think
about front-end API or front-end client
side app calls this calls this over rest
and Jason in my back-end API this thing
actually kind of just proxies to the G
RPC service and then does some
conversions of the types of objects to
give them back so I get a menu service
in this case I'm getting it from
dependency injection right here and then
I can just call this method so this
client is code generated I didn't have
to write it the fact that I import the
proto file gives me this generated
client I can call this method gives me
strongly typed objects that are code
generated to pass in the data that I
need and get the data that I want back
out and that's how something like this
works so the other cool aspect of this
that I can show you is I've configured
something like Zipkin I've configured
distributed tracing for this for this
repository or for my sample so Zipkin is
a distributed tracing dashboard and in
all of these applications I have wired
them up to do distributed tracing to
this instance so I'm running a service
for Zipkin in my kubernetes instance and
i have put this little bit of like
telemetry code
in all the services that are deployed
here what's going to happen is that all
the HTTP coming into the application all
the HTTP going out of the application as
well as the Redis calls that are going
out of the application are going to go
and get traced to the Zipkin instance
additionally if you wanted to trace your
sort of arbitrary stuff there's this
activity type that you can interact with
in Dona Corps and you can sort of set up
your own your own little areas or
regions of time to add to the data
that's going to Zipkin David and
Damian's talk from yesterday about
diagnostics included a lot of this
information as well perhaps at a little
bit more level of detail so if you want
to learn more about that I would suggest
watching that when the video comes out
if you didn't catch it so what I'm going
to do right now is I'm going to trace
one of these calls to toppings so I'm
going to search for calls that came in
to the path to slash toppings I can open
that here in Zipkin and I can see that I
got a request to my front-end I can see
that the user agent was was maxed so it
was it was this computer
it was the app I showed you and then you
can see that there was another there was
another call here that happened kind of
overlapping in time and this was the
call to menu service get topping so like
this URL right here I didn't have to
write that in code anywhere it comes
from GRP CG RPC decides what that URL is
and you can see that the client was G
RPC so you can see that I've got this
little like sort of waterfall chart here
of what's going on in my application
what are the calls that went to various
services and what were their results
which is very valuable when something
goes wrong and you want to see what
happens let's look at something slightly
more complicated one of these more
complex G RPC invocations so I mentioned
that I'm using G RPC for the order
processing portion as well so we can
look at something slightly more complex
here and that would be I happen to know
what the URL is so when I place the
order it goes to slash orders and
there's more that's going on inside of
here
so my front end app makes a call to
orders then that goes to the orders G
RPC service so you can see this is a G
RPC looking kind of URL and it's a gr PC
dotnet client and then the next thing is
you can see that there's some extra
stuff happening here this is the
communication that's happen
inside the order service with Redis so
you can see you can see things here like
what what exactly what statement was
being executed in Redis Redis is kind of
this like Cru language sort of thing you
can also see the hostname of the
reticence ins that I was talking to
which is an azure hosted Redis that I
provisioned and all the events that
happened as part of that communication
the other thing that's really cool about
distributed tracing and why you why
you'd like this sort of thing is you can
go down here and you can get these IDs
so these IDs are the things that make
distributed tracing work and they flow
around in headers on all the
communication that's happening inside
your micro services app so asp net core
this is a standard by the way we didn't
invent it we did invent our own thing
but this is this is a standard version
of it this is a standard called open
telemetry that Google and us us
Microsoft and a couple other companies
are investing in and it's basically
agreement on what these header names are
and what the values look like and what
the semantics of them are so that no
matter what kind of programming stack
you're using you can have these similar
kinds of experiences now the part that's
in dotnet core is the fact that when a
request comes in and it's stamped with
one of these headers we will do the
right thing for you inside Donette core
to wire that up to propagate those so it
means that here i have a trace ID and i
have a span ID on my incoming request
from the browser in my call to g RPC
I've also got a span ID and a parent
span ID because we've propagated that
information from the original call and
that's what powers this this sort of
diagram is the relationships between
these traces as well as the information
about when they start and when they stop
let's look at a slightly more advanced G
RPC example that I've done here which is
that my delivery service is able to push
updates and we're able to receive
updates and I want to go to my manager
app which is my little spy app here and
look at the data of how this is power so
this is a blazer server app which is why
it's able to react in in real time like
this and the really important sort of
money part of this is this on selected
order change so when I selected in that
drop-down I want to monitor order number
two this is the code that ran so again
I've got a JR PC client I go to track
the delivery I pass in the user ID
in the order idea I'm interested in and
then I get a response from the delivery
server but instead of a single response
I get a streaming response and I can
call read all async on that which gives
me back a c-sharp eight icing away table
or I sink innumerable and I have
something that I can then async for each
or a weight for each and get each
message as it comes back so that's how
I'm able to like stream those status
messages in it's coming back a
synchronously as the server pushes them
to me we call this in G RPC server push
if I wanted to see how that's
implemented I can go into I can go into
this G RPC application and take a look
so in in the G RPC in the delivery
service application I've got this G RPC
service the delivery service and it's
got two endpoints it's got delivery
status which returns a single status and
it's got track delivery which is what
returns a stream of these delivery
statuses and inside here not going to
explain this code in super detail but
you can look at the sample if you want
I'm basically listening to a Redis
pub/sub and every time I get a message
on that Redis topic I'm gonna fetch the
current state of where that driver is
and I'm and the current status of that
pizza delivery and I'm going to push it
out over that G RPC connection if
anybody's listening to me so this is
like a flexible way to have people
subscribe when they want notifications
they can hang up when they don't want
them anymore and the server just tells
you gives you continual updates of what
the status of that pizza is so how these
things are produced we're going to talk
a little bit about Redis now inside my
Delivery Service
I've got a couple things happening so I
mentioned I've got this G RPC service
here and I've also got this hosted
service so hosted service and asp net
core is typically going to derive from
the background service class and if you
haven't seen these before you probably
have written something like this or have
wanted something like this in the past
and you might not know that we already
have it so definitely check that out
background service is the thing is the
thing that you want to reach for if you
want some job running in your process in
your service that is going to have the
same lifetime as the service but it's
not going to handle any requests so in
this case my background service awaits
and it basically just subscribes to a
message queue in this case I'm
subscribing to the orders message
q so this this GU here is kind of how
you do message queues and Redis I'm
listening to a topic I'm looking at a
list and saying are there any orders
that need to be processed and then I'm
listening on a topic to get notified
when that list is updated so that I can
check again basically so I'm pulling
orders off of this message queue and
then every time I get an order I'm gonna
process it and you've now reached the
point where the veil just completely
shatters on my demo so there's no actual
pizza store anywhere here I know you're
shocked right there's no actual delivery
person that's bringing these pizzas
anywhere it's all simulated this is the
code that simulates that pizza delivery
and this is the code that pushes those
updates out so we pick a time we pick a
timer of a minute and we interpolate
from wherever we said the pizza store
was to where we saying that the person
is and push out updates like every three
seconds or every five seconds with the
drivers new position of just them moving
closer and closer until it's delivered
so we totally fake the pizza status
thing so something you might be asking
yourself at this point would be why am I
using Redis to do this communication
inside of a single process because I
said that the G RPC service for delivery
and the Redis service for processing
orders and pushing out status updates
are actually in the same service and the
reason is because of statefulness and
because of scaling so my micro services
here is stateful because if somebody
subscribes if somebody subscribes to get
updates for an order they want to get
updates for that order no matter where
that order is being processed but since
I'm reading the orders from a message
queue only one app at a time is
processing those updates
so the fact that I can put something
like a Redis in between means that no
matter how many instances I have of my
delivery service
anybody can subscribe to notifications
for any order on any delivery service
they don't have to guess which delivery
service is the one that processed that
order the updates flow to everybody
could I have made these two services I
probably could have made them two
services so there's all these
technologies that we're using here and
all these different ways that were sort
of inter connecting and talking to
different services but we haven't talked
about solving any of the questions of
how you find them or how you talk to
them
well kubernetes has kind of got your
back for this
there's a couple things that kubernetes
does that can really simplify your life
when it comes to microservices
communication and how you find other
services so the like dumbest thing you
could do is you could do this so i'm
going to make this slightly bigger so
you can see and I'm gonna say coop
control yet service this is listing for
me all the services when it decides to
this is going to list for me all the
services that are running in this
namespace in my cluster and you can see
I've got some of my apps services here
delivery front-end manager menu orders
as all the things I mentioned as well as
stuff that's infrastructure like
Prometheus which I'll talk about it in a
little bit and you can see for some of
these for all of these I have a cluster
IP and for some of them I have an
external IP so I've got an address that
I can use to communicate with this
service inside the cluster and then I've
got an external load balancer address
that I can use to talk to outside the
cluster well these service names are
actually just host names so for instance
if I wanted to if I'm inside the
delivery service and I wanted to talk to
the front-end service or talk to the
menu service I could literally just HTTP
menu and that would work just fine so
kind of like the dumbest thing you can
do if you're on kubernetes is you can
just use DNS because kubernetes uses all
those features so kubernetes will create
dns records for all your services you
don't actually need to know how to find
them the logical name that you gave to
the service is the hostname is the
address what if you wanted to do
something else so let me show you
something that I like to do when I write
this kind of application I like to I
like to basically make these things work
but make them work with a default so in
my startup code here I've got this
little helper
configuration get service hostname and
I'm passing in what I want the defaults
of these host names to be so for the
delivery service I'm gonna hard code and
assume that if nobody's told me
otherwise I can talk to it on delivery
likewise for menu and orders if nobody's
told me otherwise I'm gonna assume that
the logical name of the service is the
hostname the nice thing about that
assumption is that that will work really
well if you're on kubernetes and you
have a simple configuration it will also
work really well if you're running
locally with something like docker
compose and other things that are multi
host container kinds of systems that
provide DNS and networking services
which would be all of them
this kind of really simple scheme is
supported by a bunch of different stuff
if I wanted to get more complex with it
let's look at what this code does so
this code is going to use the I
configuration object that you get in asp
net core and i'm going to going
i've got a simple convention around what
keys i use so I take the logical name of
the service and so I'm looking for a key
service : and then the service name and
whatever is there I'm going to assume is
supposed to be the URL of this key what
I like about this design and what I like
about doing things like this is first of
all I can provide a default so I don't
have to set this everywhere because it
would be kind of a pain second of all if
you don't have the information you need
like fail like fail hard fail very
clearly with a clear error message so if
I don't have a reasonable default and I
didn't provide a configuration value
like this service will fail to start
like if you have messed up the
configuration of something like it will
fail in a very clear way with a very
clear error message so that you know
what the problem is and you're not
hunting around with like a bad error
message or a timeout or something like
that failing fast and failing loudly can
really help you if you wanted to you
could go even further or you could say
something like I'm gonna have a health
check that looks to say can I at least
ping that thing or can I at least verify
that I've got configuration there's a
couple different ways to fail what this
would look like to actually configure it
the sort of simplest thing to do is well
you could use an environment variable so
in a spinet core if I wanted to override
this I could provide a value for this
with the environment variable let's say
for the order service like service
underscore underscore orders it's not a
mistake it's two underscores it's
supposed to be two underscores two
underscores we let you use one
underscore for readability in
environment variable names in config two
underscores in a spinet core means this
is a separator so it's effectively
replaced with a colon if I were using
JSON configuration or something like
that instead
oops if I were using JSON configuration
or something like that instead then you
know I would make an object service
and then orders and so on so you get the
idea so we have a hierarchical
configuration system it has a variety of
sources it will give you a little
starter JSON file in every project by
default when you're thinking about micro
services and deploying to the cloud you
really end up first thinking about
things like environment variables it's
sort of like the easiest thing to do
because environment variables are very
foolproof and they're very easy to
troubleshoot because they're very easy
to inspect with like any sort of tool
but where you probably don't want to use
environment variables is you probably
don't want to use environment variables
for your secret data the reason we don't
like environment variables for secret
data is that they're kind of inspectable
by like anyone so if you have access to
the machine or you have access to look
in the like kubernetes UI to find out
what's going on with a pod then like
chances are you can see the environment
variables of that and you can see
whatever data is in there is just sort
of plain text so like we don't end up we
don't want to use environment variables
for secrets what do we want to do
instead well the answer is that we can
still just use configuration because in
asp net core your secrets come in
through configuration anyway that's how
things like secret manager or key vault
work in Azure things get mapped in
through your through your configuration
system the configuration system is how
we read those things but how would we
get a value into our service in the
first place so in my order service I
need to talk to Redis I also do this in
the delivery service and the way that I
can get this secret in here is I've
defined a secret already in kubernetes
so I use the kubernetes command line to
define a secret for my Redis I basically
went to Azure provision to Redis
instance and then I went to kubernetes
and I put that connection string in a
kubernetes secret using the command line
since I'm on Azure if I had wanted to I
could use key vault and import a key
vault into kubernetes you could do the
same thing on other cloud providers as
well it's kind of a standard integration
that they all provide but I just did a
normal vanilla secret and the way that I
do this is I can take this secret and I
can map it to a file and that file name
is the service underscore underscore
Redis that we talked about so basically
by mapping that secret to a file with a
name that matches the configuration key
that I wanted to use I can easily get it
inside
app the app code what the app code looks
like for that is inside my program so
yes of out of the configuration store so
this path matches what I put in that
kubernetes manifest it's gonna find
files in this directory and it's going
to map the contents of each of those
files in as a configuration value so
it's going to take the file name as the
key and the value that's in the file as
the as this as the value this
configuration source has got a pretty
bad name it should probably just say add
kubernetes configuration because this
was written specifically for kubernetes
is configuration system but but there
you go anyway so on the monitoring front
on the sort of on the sort of
diagnostics and monitoring form front
there's a couple things to say about
this one of the things to say about this
is logging and logging dashboards espy
net core has got a what we call a
structured logging system where we log
not only a textual message but we also
log key value pairs when you're running
in these cloud sort of environments what
the standard thing to do is to use like
a JSON formatted logger you can use
Sarah log for this which is really good
I don't have that set up here and I'm
not going to show a logging dashboard as
part of this demo but the information is
out there that's available if you want
it one of the really cool things that
you can do with that which damien and
David showed and their Diagnostics talk
is you can take those trace IDs from
Zipkin you can go to your logging
dashboard and you can put that into a
query and then you can see all the logs
from all the services that executed on
that trace these kinds these are the
kinds of things that you'll find pretty
essential when you're debugging and
building applications like this is you
want to set yourself up for success with
easy ways to see all the Diagnostics
across all your different apps
I did mention Zipkin already which is
I'm hooking up Zipkin here via the open
telemetry package the other piece of
magic that I have got here is I'm
tracking metrics from these applications
so I'm using a package called Prometheus
net which is a lovely community package
that someone has made and I've got this
middleware here that's that's tracking
HTTP metrics this sits in between
routing and endpoints and the reason why
it sits in between routing and endpoints
is it's going to capture the results of
routing so it's going to look at what
routing decisions were made and it's
going to incorporate that data
into the telemetry kind of information
that it locks and then this endpoint
down here is going to expose an endpoint
on the slash metrics URL so one of the
things that I've done with all of these
services that you might want to think
about is I've configured for all of
these apps I'm basically listening on
both 80 and 8080 and the reason why I'm
doing that is I'm directing all of my
Diagnostics related tracing and all of
my Diagnostics related traffic to 8080
the reason why I might care about that
is that things like metrics monitoring
systems and health monitoring systems
typically don't play super well with
your your various different kinds of
authentication they may not play well
with HTTP - they may not always play
well with TLS depending on what the
system is and it's nice to be able to
separate your applications like
production traffic from your Diagnostics
only traffic one of the new features
that we added in routing in 3.0 that I'm
pretty happy with is you have the
ability to filter on endpoints filter
endpoints on port or filter endpoints on
hostname and things like that so one of
the things you might think about as
you're building applications is like
well should we listen on a separate port
for our Diagnostics traffic and should
we filter that port out so that those
things are not accessible over a normal
over a normal sort of connection to our
public endpoint so like in this case if
I wanted to for this metrics endpoint
for this health checks endpoint like I
could require some type of authorization
if I wanted to I could filter by host I
could implement various other policies
that sort of filter what traffic can go
where in my application the routing
system is extensible to do all those
things and you'll find a couple of them
built-in by default so the reason why I
have these metrics endpoints exposed is
I'm using something called Prometheus in
this cluster what I'm showing you right
here is Griffin ax which is a which is a
popular metrics sort of visualization
tool for Prometheus and the way that
this sort of work speaks to the power
and the flexibility of kubernetes
there's a there's a demon or a sort of
worker running in my cluster or a set of
workers running in my cluster that are
going to go to all my services and hit
that metrics endpoint at intervals I
think it does like every 30 seconds by
default and it's going to basically ask
that and
point what data do you have that you
want to share with me that I will then
take in use there's also a bunch of
metrics gathering information that you
get from kubernetes by default when you
install something like Prometheus in it
so like I've thrown Prometheus on this
cluster and I can see here for the
blazing pizza namespace where my app is
deployed
what's the CPU usage of an in a stack
chart format of all the different apps
that are running here and you can see
that there's a little bump in activity
when we were actually using my app from
a couple minutes ago
about you know at about 10:45 when I
really got into demoing stuff and then
after that it's been pretty quiet
because we're just sitting here it's a
little early for pizza likewise you can
look at things like CPU requests and
quotas if I had assigned requests and
quotas which I'll explain in a minute to
my apps how am i doing against those
quotas am I using all the resources that
I allocated for these pods or am I not
likewise you get things like memory
usage and network traffic and things
like that and you can get a lot of this
stuff for free without even doing
anything to your apps because when you
install prometheus in a cluster you're
gonna get a lot of these things for free
now the major cloud providers all have
similar kind of offerings for this
I know asher's is called Azure monitor
other crowd providers have similar
offerings to this I'm showing Prometheus
today instead of showing like Azure
monitor a to avoid leaking any of my a
jerk retentions to you and B to give a
sort of cloud provider neutral view of
what's possible the kubernetes and
Griffin o stuff is really probably Best
of Breed all the cloud providers have
something similar but that might not
might not be as powerful but it also
might be set up for you a little bit
easier out of the box since it's just
gonna come with your kubernetes instance
the other thing that I've done here that
I want to show you is I have written my
own dashboard using the metrics that are
exposed by my apps and these are coming
from that metrics endpoint that I
exposed in my apps now I'm a total
Prometheus has its own like graphing and
query language that's fairly complex and
I'm a total newbie at this I'm actually
proud of what I was able to accomplish
I've got a little graph here that shows
the requests the number of requests
coming into the app as well as the
number of failed requests coming
the app so I can I can pick in this
picker which of my apps is running and
how many how many requests are coming in
within a given period of time and how
many of those were failures are non 200s
within that same period of time the
reason why there's some baseline level
of traffic to all these apps despite the
fact that we're not actually using them
for anything is because I've got those
health checks running so kubernetes is
poking all my apps being like hey you
all right you all right you all right
the other thing I want to mention about
this is that this is data driven so like
I didn't actually have to write down
anywhere what are the names of all the
apps that you want to that you want to
monitor and I also didn't have to write
down what are the names of all the apps
that you want it to show up in the
monitoring dashboard as options so
hopefully this gives you an idea of some
of the kinds of things that you get you
can get for performance monitoring and
for troubleshooting and for examining
and diagnosing problems I think that the
kinds of performance oriented things
that Prometheus can show you and other
cloud-based solutions can show you
probably more advanced than what most of
us use on a day to day basis and there's
really a lot of mileage to get out of
these kinds of systems without spending
a lot of time setting them up so with
that I alluded to earlier something
called something called requests and
limits for containers so part of
kubernetes is the is the fact that
kubernetes decides where your apps run
right so when I said I want to have
three copies of this app I didn't have
to say I want one on each machine or
anything like that
kubernetes actually allocates your apps
where it thinks is best you have some
ways to influence that in some ways to
control it but one of the rules that
matters the most is you can tell
kubernetes how much resources a given
app wants and it will put it where it
thinks is best or put it where it thinks
it can accommodate your expectations for
amount of resources for that app which
is pretty cool but I think as well as
Donette developers were like a little
bit in the dark about this like what
what does it even mean to figure out
what kind of resources your app will
need like how would you even go if you
if you if I told you you know you're
gonna start using kubernetes and you're
gonna start needing to understand the
resource requirements of
your apps where would you start today
and the answer is I think a lot of us
would like draw a big blank like how
would I even figure that out
so I've done an experiment I wanted to
basically do some of my own performance
testing around this we we know that asp
net core and donna core can perform
really well when we're talking about
high throughput with lots of lots of
traffic and access to lots of hardware
see the tech and power benchmarks if you
don't know what I'm talking about
we've got industry-leading performance
for HTTP in terms of frameworks and
tools and technologies you'd actually
want to use but how do we do when you're
thinking about things that have to scale
down really small like how do we do when
you've got a really small amount of
resources this comes up a lot when
you've got like I've got a bunch of apps
that I need to run they're separate
because that's the way I wanted to
architect it but some of these are
really low traffic like I don't need to
send a lot of data from them I don't
need to receive a lot of data from them
how would they do with low resources or
if you want to write the kind of
structure that runs in kubernetes some
of the things that kubernetes provides
you that run inside the run inside the
cluster itself are allocated like 50
Meg's of memory and like 1/10 of a CPU
core so let's take a look at that this
is what it looks like by the way I'm
going to speed up a little bit because
we're almost out of time here this is
what it looks like to actually define
requests and limits for one of your
containers or one of your pods this is
something you will have to do if you
want to use auto scaling so kubernetes
has the ability to do auto scaling based
on load you can't do that unless you
define what what you think normal looks
like for an application the experiment
that I did is I wrote the same app in a
bunch of different text acts so go
Python Java at the kinds of things that
people think about writing cloud and
micro services types of applications and
I measured those with fixed amounts of
requests per second and I varied the
amount of CPU and memory allocated to
them using docker so our test
environment has the ability to run
docker we have a pretty robust
benchmarking setup in the office and I'm
able to simulate a kubernetes kind of
environment by just using docker and
then I'm measuring latency working set
CPU usage and the percentage of traffic
actually served the reason why that last
one is there is if I asked for 100
requests per second and
gave me 50 like 50% is enough like you
fail right so we want to know how what
percentage of the traffic they were
expected to serve that they actually
served and the intent here is to
simulate what it's like for a small
microservices app getting a predictable
amount of traffic so the experiment has
you have incoming HTTP incoming JSON
serialization outgoing HTTP outgoing
JSON serialization and most importantly
calling some other service that has some
amount of delay so if it were
instantaneous it's kind of artificial
what are our micro-services apps do well
we looked at that in Zipkin right they
call other services so I wanted to
include calling another service as part
of this I wanted to see how a spinet
core would stack up here for that reason
I'm kind of redacting the names of the
other tech stacks here if you're really
curious to know the results come and
talk to me afterwards and I'll talk to
you if you promise to be mature about it
I did not want to get on stage and give
a presentation where I talk down to Java
users or NGO users or anyone else like
that
because that's just that's not very nice
I wouldn't like that if somebody did it
about.net also not every technology
claims to be good at what I'm doing so
is it a little bit unfair to throw some
of the Java frameworks into this kind of
testing maybe I think the people that
make those frameworks might say you
wouldn't be successful with this and
it'd be unfair to call them out for
something that they say won't work so
let me unpack what you're looking at
here so we've got our sort of
combinations across the bottom there's
30 Meg's times a quarter of a CPU on the
small end 360 Meg's of memory and a full
CPU on the right end something that very
smart people get confused about when
they see this and you're even smarter so
you won't get confused one CPU does not
mean one core it means one unit of CPU
so it's not one CPU does not mean your
single-threaded it means that if the
machine has 12 cores
you get 1/12 of the machine if that
makes sense you can run things in
parallel with one CPU because it does
not mean one core it means in my 12 core
CPU case 1/12 of the machine's
processing power aggregated over time
and you'll see that on the small end so
talking about this data you'll see that
on the small end there's some things
that don't appear so this this yellow
bar this great
and the sort of brownish bar don't run
they don't serve one RPS at the smallest
amount of resources that I tested but a
lot of them do right and it's only when
we get into the like point five CPU
times a hundred megabyte category that
stuff show up that ever all the
workloads show up as working one of
them's got really high latency I'm using
latency in these charts as sort of a
measure of Health ten milliseconds is
the theoretical minimum for latency in
this test so if you're around 10
milliseconds you're healthy if you're
much higher than that you're not keeping
up likewise let's bump it up to 100 and
we can see that some people some of
these stacks start to struggle we can
see that whoever is in green is starting
to have a hard time at 100 whoever's in
gray is having a little bit of trouble
at the smallest amount of numbers and
doing well at higher numbers cool let's
bump it up to a thousand whoa you can
see that a lot of stuff dropped out
right so a lot of our stacks dropped out
a lot of them are not able to do it at
the smallest amount of requests let's
bump it up to 10,000 ooh
so we've reached a limit here we're at
the small at these very small
configurations not everybody is able to
serve 10,000 requests per second which
is kind of a high number for really
small amount of resources but some of
them are able to do it with more of the
resources that we've allocated so think
about this 100 millisecond of this
hundred RPS or thousand RPS slide and
think about which ones of these you
think are dotnet quarks I'm about to
reveal to you so this is the thousand
RPS slide blue is Donna core with asp
net MVC controllers pink is Donna core
using routing and Jason and HTTP client
without MVC so if we look back at these
slides and sort of analyze this like
we're doing really well in all of these
configurations at one request per second
we're doing really well in all these
configurations at 100 requests per
second so if if you had asked me before
I did this kind of testing can I write
an asp net core app that's gonna run and
run well with 30 megabytes of memory and
a quarter of CPU time I would have told
you no I was really surprised by that
so it's doing pretty well it's not all
good news I think some of the bad news
here is well these benchmarks were
written by a framework architect and
they were written kind of carefully so
like it's clear that MBC is not a great
fit for all these kinds of scenarios you
can't take an MVC app and give it 30
megabytes of memory and scale it up to
crazy amounts I think we want to work on
closing that gap but if you have
scenarios like this where you want to
write a really small app that does a lot
of stuff think about dropping the level
of abstraction think about going to
lower level concepts to get more
performance out I'm going to speed
through a couple other things because we
are over time so this is a heat map this
show is basically success so think about
more resources as you go from left to
right
more RPS as you go from top to bottom
green means good red means bad this top
left one and bottom center one are the
two asp net ones so router code is the
bottom middle one so again it is
actually surprisingly good you've got a
lot of options and you've got a lot of
flexibility if you're in one of these
scenarios where you really want to run
with density this is what I'm talking
about with route to code using routing
and a low level of abstraction we're
gonna make a bunch of improvements to
this in 5.0 doing this sort of thing is
going to be a lot simpler we're taking
the JSON stuff making the performant
thing be the easiest thing to find
alright and that's the end thank you all
for being good audience enjoy the rest
of the day
[Applause]